excited I haven't been this excited in
my whole life we got out last to right
in front of us part of me is like [ __ ]
this other part of me is like [ __ ] yes
the DLC of outlast was one of the best
horror games experiences then we got in
a very very long time you're scared
don't worry papa parents is here let's
go so this is the demo we got to play
the demoing outlast one
Thank You red ballast welcome to the
outlets to demo your bleak longer money
Longman a cameraman working with your
wife in lane two of you are
investigative journalists willing to
take risks and dig deeper to uncover the
stories no one else will dare touch
you're following a trail of clues that
started with a seemingly impossible
murder of a pregnant woman known as Jane
Doe
Jane Doe everyone know pregnant ladies
can't die they got that shield from the
babies I'm sorry the investigation has
led you miles into the Arizona desert
toward darkness so deep that no one
could shed light upon it and a
corruption so profound that going mad
maybe the only sane thing to do I like
that sense okay two weeks ago a young
woman was found wandering barefoot
pregnant alone on a barren stretch of
highway a hundred miles from the nearest
town
Oh God
[Music]
holy [ __ ] that felt like real terror
[ __ ] hell gave me shivers oh god what
is this
Hey
Len Len Langerman
Oh oh [ __ ] where the hell am i yep oh
there's my glasses what am i whelming my
glasses my glasses I can't see without
my glasses
okay whoa this looks [ __ ] amazing oh
I fell down this play are we getting up
are we are come on bloggers mind you can
do it and so our outlast journey begins
to raise your camcorder press the right
mouse button oh my god
Lynn Lynn are you here oh here we are
back at it again
holy [ __ ]
oh my god I am NOT barrels wheels I hate
this up should we knock yeah oh okay
hello it's totally pot what a
piece-of-shit house hello it's sentiment
in there the [ __ ] is this shift to run
I'm not sure I ever should run downhill
that seems like a bad it what was that
what the [ __ ] is out there
oh god this is [ __ ] creepy man oh
[ __ ] okay oh Jesus crisis get the [ __ ]
out of me cactus
[ __ ] you cactus that [ __ ] hurt hit me
right in the crunch oh god it's getting
dark man it's getting well dark man
what's in here
a bucket yes of course I have the same
bucket wadded up Tesco hello Oh Jeff
Victor oh hey all right that's cool I'm
just gonna go batteries when the mine is
gonna kick are you doing that Betty dude
you look good
honestly like oh that's another traveler
doesn't it okay well don't mind if I
take your batteries the son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] off I got my batteries I don't need
you I don't need anyone
all right come out puts out a shudder
ran out of batteries okay we got to
reload
hello Jesus whoa what the [ __ ]
who's you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh what the [ __ ] are you doing
Jesus Lynn no [ __ ] me why is their
tricycle here
that's like bad news in horror 101 oh my
god what the [ __ ] is that a cow
if only Leo was here he'd go right in
give me that Oscar I'm ready I'm ready
smells so bad [ __ ] creepy as
villagers oh [ __ ] okay
all right everyone take it okay so if I
hit alt I turn around super fast oh yeah
cuz when you run you can look behind oh
my god [ __ ] that hello there mister man
man you look good man let's go inside
it's cool it's good that Amir it's
pretty powerful the pizzeria and someone
just yelled what man alright but this is
pretty good so far getting some good
coverage for my journalists what a nice
town open window oh my god [ __ ] indeed
Jesus Christ our brain is not here what
a nice cozy hey they got corn and
everything
that's lovely anyone in here think we're
okay how's it going in here guys maybe
there's some batteries no oh you see the
audio on the cameras all right I suppose
we go out oh that's cool man this is so
[ __ ] cool all right well so far we
haven't died so I guess we'd go in here
hello everyone
mega-bear Hey all right oh [ __ ]
you know shits about to go down when the
drum starts hitting yet what a lovely
place what a nice religious town hey no
I hear you Ethan Bradberry you son of a
Bradbury the [ __ ] are you doing out
there in the woods I ain't scared
such darkness in the Miguel day I think
they spelled bananas wrong am i right
crow I'm right come all that's right
yeah no sure why not go down here this
is a great place and really enjoying
this okay let's see what wonderful
things happen down here hey it's a teddy
hey oh you're missing an idea what the
[ __ ] man let's find your ID Teddy this
is probably some nest of demons that's
fine no big deal okay oh what a lovely
chandelier it's so pretty I wonder where
they got it oh dude that's not a carpet
that's babies
uh-oh the [ __ ] man that's not cool man
oh look at it sound what do I keep
walking on them I don't know but the
[ __ ] forgot a [ __ ] up by last is Jesus
Christ oh all right this is fantastic
man hey horse how you doing there buddy
why is the horse whispering Jimmy [ __ ]
you horse I'm gonna ride you now [ __ ] is
going on here
[ __ ] your swing
well is it hello did I just lose my
tongue virginity
alright press I'm gonna have to end that
episode there but I'll be back soon with
another episode but leave a like in the
meanwhile let me know if you wanted me
to play the full game with this I think
it reason they do it thank you so much
for watching and as always stay awesome
rest